hi film courage um my name is share
Lydell and I am a screenwriter it's nice
to meet ya I started doing sketch comedy
at second city and started writing for I
actually took the leap into full script
which is a huge leap I mean to go from
three pages to 90 at a minimum is that's
a yeah that's a lot of words oh my
current script is called line of descent
and I've been working on it for how one
say years I mean it's an idea that I had
a long time ago and I just can't not
tell stories this is something that I
have discovered within myself as I I'm a
storyteller by nature and there was this
idea that I had for this story for years
and I was just trying to figure out the
right path to go down and so I've been
writing this story in some kind of
iteration I finally just kind of got a
hold of where I want the story to go and
the characters that I want to tell the
story within the last couple of months
and so I've been writing pretty pretty
frequently this one story like most
people of my generation my biggest
influences star wars and and mmm Indiana
Jones and that kind of stuff I'm also
heavy into comedy but my biggest
influence for telling stories has been
twilight zone they have always been
intrigued by the story of man in his
mind and situations that they may go in
and how does a person react to various
emergencies or life decisions and so
this was of that vein that's why I
wanted to write it what would my
characters do given this situation what
makes a family at a friends what makes a
bloodline family is there a difference
between the two of them there were a lot
of questions that I wanted to have
answered and that's why I wanted to
tackle this story I didn't quit on it
because
it's been nagging at me for a long time
and like scripts or things to buy in the
store it fits in the back of your mind
for for more than a week or a month
something that's a story that needs to
be told my goal for these are very
interesting questions feel encouraged
these the goal for this particular
script is I'd like to see it completed
I'd love to see it out there and
viewable i would i would like to see it
finished the short term goal is I love
it Senate that would be great
screenwriting has made me more
accountable uh it's made me more like I
have to tell the story uh when do I
write at all times of day that was
something that I really wanted to make
sure that I did because I I can see
myself falling into a pattern of if
things aren't right I can't write so I
didn't ever want to be in that situation
I read somewhere that a very famous
writer could only write standing up
writing longhand on a barrel and I
remember reading that when I was like in
high school and thinking well that's
really freaking limiting I mean the
inspiration hits me at any time and when
the inspiration hits at any time then I
need to start writing it could be right
after I took a shower ideas just start
coming in as I god that's what I need to
do and so okay it's nine o'clock in the
morning I I'm gonna start writing and
then I right until you know how whenever
i'm done with that thought or I get
inspiration at six o'clock at night
right get inspiration in in in the
middle of the day um I don't I think
that it's I don't want ever wanted to
limit my imagination and my want to
write that's my can't Cleo Bonnie and
she helps my goals is to be successful
at it I mean
to be able to tell stories and that's
what I do for a living oh god how
awesome would that be writers and
writing has always seemed like some
lofty profession like it's two books and
movies were written by otherworldly
people it wasn't something that I can do
I mean writing is something that's above
us all that's kind of how I mean because
everything originated with the written
word I wrote because I felt the need to
but I never thought that I could call
myself a writer and it wasn't until I
actually i won a screenwriting contest a
couple of months ago and one of my
friends told me well do you write Mikey
and he's like well then you're a writer
it's like okay I don't get paid can you
really consider yourself I don't know
this there's not really a story to my
screen writing career it's beginning I
want a contest screenwriting I've placed
in a few things I always like to enter
contests that that you write in the
contest you don't just submit a script
it's like it gives you parameters and
then you have like 24 hours to write I
like to enter those contests to keep the
skill level up and I think that that's
important as well is like you know if
you write a script it's great null and
you can fine tune it and you can you
know twist it and get the nuts a little
tighter and all that crap but if you put
all of your eggs in that one basket
you're you're not you're you're limiting
yourself to what more is out there and I
think that that's also important Thank
You film courage and anybody who watches
this my name again is share ladle and
the the script that I'm working on is
called line of descent have a great day
mama